[Musique]
il y a quelques temps nous avons
inauguré ce stade avec la venue du
vice-président monsieur jacotté qui est
venu ici qui était impressionné
justement par la qualité de ses
installations et avec la Fédération
Française de Cyclisme ils nous ont
proposé nous avons bien sûr accepté
d'organiser une étape de la Coupe de
France de VTT Trial
[Musique]
il y aura à partir de 8h les
compétitions jusqu'à 20h avec bien sûr
des podiums qui seront étalonnés tout au
long de la journée et entre ces podiums
et ses différentes épreuves des
démonstrations de breakdance
on va parler des pôles un peu partout en
France et même à l'international parce
qu'on aura des pilotes bien entendu
l'élite française des pilotes mais on
aura aussi des pilotes internationaux
donc on va faire rayonner d'une part ce
stade Julien Absalon mais par la même
rayonner toute la ville d'épônes
voir
un pilote sur la roue arrière à 2 mètres
du sol sur des obstacles comme ça et
faire des sauts extraordinaires je veux
dire c'est on voit pas ça tous les jours
et on a peut-être vu une fois ou l'autre
à la télévision mais quand on le voit en
réalité qu'on est au pied d'un parce
qu'on sera au contact direct avec ces
pilotes
[Musique]